straighten my hair and it looks like
[ __ ] looks good this looks good this
looks good and you can't tell me
otherwise you can tell me but it just
like this is a very exciting day ah
we've passed three million subscribers
here on the it's great YouTube channel
and um uh and in the grand scheme of
YouTube that might not seem significant
or interesting or unique but it is
significant and interesting and unique
to me it's uh and also ah for those of
you that do not know much about me hi my
name is grace Helbig he did not know now
you know your life is different now I
started out my youtube career on a
channel called Daily Grace which is now
called daily you worked for a website
called My Damn Channel com I made videos
for them and they owned everything that
I did and the channel amassed like two
point four or so or two point two or
something million subscribers and um I
didn't own any of anything about that
channel and so a couple years ago I was
forced to leave that channel and start
this channel so it's always been
silently a huge milestone that I wanted
to hit passing three million subscribers
because the Daily Grace Channel had you
know over 2 million subscribers um but
it didn't have over 3 million
subscribers and so for some it can't
really explain it but um this is very
significant to me so thank you I feel
very happy and motivated and inspired so
I thought today's video I would do
something called 50 truths and a lie
combining the 50 facts about me and the
two truths and a lie
thing into one because maybe some of you
don't know a lot about me and maybe some
of you know a lot about me and you can
spot the lie so here's 50 things about
though here's 51 things about me and one
of them is a lie I got to keep track of
the
because I did not prep for this video
one I used to work for website called My
Damn Channel com I used to have a
youtube channel called Daily Grace I've
never had my tonsils taken out I'm
wearing green liquid eyeliner and I
still feel insecure I own Tarot thirds
my very first job was in the fitting
room at a TJ Maxx oh there's a I believe
in ghosts I did triple jump when I was
in high school that this video sucks I
have one tattoo I've never had a bikini
wax was important content my very first
car was a Dodge Intrepid and I nicknamed
it the Ox which is double weird because
in Chinese zodiac I was born in 85 and
I'm an ox I've never had a UTI that I
have definitively known about I can make
myself purport I was in a spelling bee
in fifth grade and I was eliminated
because of the word predicate I refused
to this day to learn how to spell the
word predicate when I was 19 I did a
winter break study abroad in London and
I thought I was so cool and I went to
this market and I bought a t-shirt that
I thought was so representative of my
style and my quirk and it was pink and
it had a big print on it and it said
Mary is my homegirl and I wore it to all
the bars no much has evolved I've taken
a Zumba class on ironically I caught a
Pikachu pokémon girl in science class in
seventh grade I tried to hold my art
classroom snake to be cool and I got so
afraid that I dropped it on the ground
and the teacher got upset and I just
hated myself for months and
I'm fine now when I was in third grade
going into fourth grade I cheated on my
eye exam I squinted so that I couldn't
read the letters that they showed me so
that I could get glasses because I
thought that was super cool see you
there I do not know how to knit
I do not know how to drive stick shift
there were less than 160 kids in my high
school graduating class my senior year I
won the senior superlative nicest smile
I have a minor in theater but just like
minor league baseball I have ten toes no
job that I got paid actual physical
money for doing was being a tennis
instructor what I do not know how to
change my car's oil I worked at four
different chain restaurants and one of
those chain restaurants I worked at two
separate locations of when I was younger
my older brother and I used to watch WWF
at the time and we would recreate our
own versions of the bushwhackers that
probably doesn't make sense to any of
you it was important to my growth and
development as an adult and a mature
functional human I have had my belly
button pierced one time when I was
living in Brooklyn I unexpectedly spent
a full week day comforting a friend of
mine that have recently been broken up
with ie drinking heavily into the night
and on my walk home to my apartment that
night I picked up a tiny ironing board
out of someone else's garbage and I kept
that ironing board in my apartment under
the day I moved out of New York I hugged
Tony Robbins and he has called me by my
own name without me informing him of
what my own name is I have never seen
Oprah in her life I've been to at least
three
bull riding competitions by choice
the very first interview I ever got kind
of hired to do with celebrities years
and years and years ago I ended up
crying on the street in New York - my
best friend Michelle you got to start
somewhere
I've done improv shows based on
pornography I'm a small part in a hugely
amazing film called dirty thirty coming
out this September you can pre-order it
a dirty thirty movie.com got happy get I
had to I had to shut up I used to play
clarinet and one time in fifth grade
before recital I got so nervous that I
put so much Lube on my clarinet that it
fell apart in between songs I do not
play clarinet anymore my first major
crush in high school was Billy Elliot
all my friends have pictures of Leo
DiCaprio from Titanic in their lockers
and I had a picture of it very brawny
boy doing ballet in my locker got start
somewhere I'm afraid of being in the hot
air balloon I've never done a keg stand
some of my Halloween costumes have been
but are not limited to half of Hans and
Franz Bugs Bunny and it did piece of
grass I have audition for SNL in front
of Lorne Michaels Chloe didn't get it
okay that's it for this video I hope you
guys enjoyed it if you did please
subscribe to this channel because now
there's over three million of you and
let's shoot for four because Tony's
moderation or you can sleep with excess
oh and if you think you know the lie
write in the comments down below
somehow I'll reveal over some sort of
social media which one was the lie so
make sure you're following me across all
social media and because you passed
three million I'm gonna do a giveaway to
you guys that's right you mother first
these beauties are still right here I am
going to give away these three backpacks
to three of you wonderful humans who
have subscribed to my youtube channel
and they're gonna be filled with a bunch
of awesome Shh not feces I can't tell
you exactly what's gonna be in those
things because I have not planned that
far that's just me Oh me it's gonna be
just like a grace pack no longer a
backpack but a grace pack so I have to
do is be subscribed to my youtube
channel follow me on Twitter
and Instagram and leave a sweet comment
on this video that was that that's it
that's literally like to do and maybe
want to be a win we will announce it
soon big bake bake bake bake bake bake
because I don't know I don't like I
don't like this I like this I don't like
this I'm afraid of everything
et scared me haunted houses scare me and
this you turn on right now are you guys
stay off you go say on this scares me
right now